la ley que fue aprobada hace pocas horas
en la cámara baja del parlamento y que
para entrar en vigencia también deberá
ser aprobada en el senado obligaría a
los gigantes tecnológicos como facebook
y google a pagarles a los medios de
comunicación australianos por difundir
sus noticias según el gobierno federal
de australia en promedio por cada 100
dólares gastados en publicidad en línea
google captura 53 dólares y facebook 28
dólares y el resto se reparte entre
otros privando así a los medios de
comunicación a recibir ingresos
necesarios para financiar su periodismo
google y facebook se han defendido
diciendo que por el contrario sus
servicios sus plataformas lo que hacen
es beneficiar a los medios de
comunicación pues generan tráfico clics
visitas hacia los medios que pueden
desde su sitio web vender también
publicidad pues hoy la molestia en
australia es grande principalmente en
los medios en el gobierno federal pues
las páginas de facebook de medios de
comunicación amanecieron bloqueadas pero
también algunas páginas que nada tienen
que ver con medios de comunicación
algunas de éstas gubernamentales y de
servicio al ciudadano también
amanecieron bloqueadas y facebook ha
dicho que se trató de un error
empezar a desbloquear las gradualmente
por lo pronto el gobierno federal ha
rechazado esta decisión de facebook y se
mantiene impulsando esta ley y ha dicho
que no va a ceder ante intimidaciones de
estos gigantes tecnológicos de ser
aprobada esta normativa podría traer
consecuencias internacionales pues
muchos países están viendo qué sucede
entre australia y los gigantes
tecnológicos para también tomar
decisiones